So this is going to be a two-hour discussion, but in seven minutes.
So optimization of haplotransplant, 2026 perspective.
No disclosures.
This is the overview of what we will discuss.
Optimization mainly through donor selection, as well as other factors.
So when we're selecting a donor, there are so many factors to consider.
Obviously, not all of them are equal.
So the question is, which ones of these factors are actually important that we should prioritize?
When we look at the NMDP guidelines for selecting haplotransplants, there isn't really much
to guide the process.
However, they do say to avoid DSA, I don't think there's any ambiguity about this.
They do say select a younger donor, specifically younger than 31 years.
We'll talk more about that.
They do also suggest that there are certain HLA factors that we should be considering.
So donor age from the very first seminal study in 2001 had been shown to be associated with survival.
Since 2001 to now, there has been a tremendous amount of studies that showed us that there is an association with survival.
So much so that it is now part of the guidelines for donors.
However, as you can see, there is multiple variations to what is the exact age that we should be selecting for our donors.
Now, the problem with this is that we don't have an exact age.
The problem with this is that when you're thinking about saying a donor is either young or old,
you're essentially putting the donors in two different buckets.
In every group, you're assuming that everyone has the same risk factors.
So we're saying a 31-year-old is similar to a 65-year-old donor, and that just biologically doesn't make sense.
When we looked at donor age in a recent era and we used conditional methods,
we saw that there is no association between donor age and overall survival.
So we saw that the relationship between donor age and survival was rather non-linear.
So you can see that the optimal age of a donor is not linear.
So we saw that the relationship between donor age and survival is rather non-linear.
The ideal age for donors is somewhere between 20 to mid-40s.
So there is more flexibility than what we think when we come up with these arbitrary age cutoffs.
And what that gives you also is the opportunity to consider other factors for selection of donors.
We know that donor age is influenced by multiple factors, including patient's age,
as well as conditioning regimen intensity.
When we used machine learning models to look at the interaction between patient age,
and donor age, we found that there is a significant synergistic effect
where you have the worst survival when you pair an older patient with an older donor,
as you can see here in this heat map with the yellow corner.
The best outcomes in the lower risk of mortality were associated with younger patients
who are paired with a donor that's somewhere between 20 to mid-40s.
Again, it shows you that donor age is not an independent factor,
but rather it's modulated by multiple factors,
including patient age.
So this foundational study showed us that in terms of HLA,
there is a specific favorable HLA profile that we should be or recommended for us to follow.
This is a B-liter match, DQ match, DR mismatch, and DPB1 non-permissive mismatch.
When we looked at recent era of transplant, again, using machine learning models,
we found that the non-permissive, the DPB1 non-permissive mismatch is actually associated with worse survival.
However, B-liter and DQ match continued to show survival benefits.
We also were able to rank these HLA so we can choose which ones are more important than others.
And with this, we have a suggested favorable HLA profile, which is DPB1 avoidance of non-permissive mismatch,
but continue to look for B-liter and DQ matches.
So how can you put all of this together?
We came up with a prediction of a predictive model that,
we stratified our patients into four different quartiles,
and this is based on their three-year overall survival.
And if you do use the best donor case based on these HLA markers and the donor age range from 20 to early 40s,
you're actually able to improve the prediction of your patient's survival.
So for instance, patients in the orange here in the third quartile, they have a prediction of 20% at three years,
and you're able to improve that up to 50%.
Patients who have the worst outcome at 10% were actually able to improve up to 30%.
So donor selection can actually improve your predicted survival of patients when you're using a donor, a haplodonor.
Other factors that may not be as considered when we're looking at selection.
So bone marrow have been associated with lower GVHD.
However, it hasn't changed our practice much.
We know that peripheral blood continues to be the,
most commonly used and generally as we talked,
donor age seems to be always more considered than other factors.
We saw that with peripheral blood and female donors,
the risk of chronic GVHD is much higher than if you choose an older donor.
So you can see here,
if you go from an 18-year-old to a 50-year-old donor,
using a bone marrow male graft has a risk factor of 27% with chronic GVH,
which is still,
still lower than using an 18-year-old female peripheral blood graft.
So it is important to consider other factors,
knowing that we have the flexibility.
Conditioning regimen,
probably one of the most controversial topic in transplant.
Now we know that it is influenced by multiple factors,
including donor type, patient age.
We did not find that myeloablation provide any survival outcomes,
survival benefits in AML, MDS, and AMC.
MPN, irrespective of age.
Surprisingly, we did find that in ALL,
reduced intensity flucide TBI was associated with superior outcomes in terms of survival,
similar relapse in lower NRM.
This is still a work in progress.
However, we did share this in EBMT just a couple of weeks ago,
but it is important to emphasize that myeloablation is not always the answer.
We know that a third of our patients don't have matched donors,
and with the donor selection prognosis score,
we know now that we're able to predict which of these donors are less likely to have an unrelated matched donor,
which allows us to move to transplant without delays.
And the BMT CT on 1702 showed us that the overall survival is similar between those patients.
We also know that a second and a third degree haploid donors have the same outcomes as a first degree.
So expanding
the search and moving early is important.
Future directions.
We are using machine learning models to personalize donor selection,
where you can use these calculators and input all of the complex factors.
This is led by Ritesh Mehta in our department.
And in conclusion, donor selection can improve your predicted survival of your patients.
We know that HLA factors are important and should be considered for survival, patient age and disease risk,
are more dominant factors, more so than donor age.
We should be avoiding older haploid donors.
If you have an older patient, maybe you can expand beyond the first degree.
Consider grandchildren.
Haploid donor search should be done early and upfront without delays.
We know that arbitrary age cutoffs can be misleading and we know that age is actually flexible,
which allows you to consider other factors such as a male donor and bone marrow and myeloablation is
not always the answer. And with that, I thank you for your attention.